what's standing out okay let's get to
the most important thing first of all
the company is cutting its forecast for
deliveries for the full year as we know
Tesla had seen about 55,000 deliveries
of its Model S and it's yet to be
introduced Model X SUV now it says it's
a range of 50 to 55 thousand vehicles
the company says it's still on track to
introduce that Model X SUV at the end of
the third quarter but the deliveries
number for this quarter that just
reported the second quarter eleven
thousand five hundred and thirty two it
says the number in the third quarter
should be twelve thousand but again it
is cutting the forecast for the full
year deliveries is really what people
have been focusing on for Tesla both a
question of how many cars then can the
company produce and what is the actual
demand out there now I'm seeing a number
that the second quarter production was
actually twelve thousand eight hundred
and seventy seven vehicles that was the
production the deliveries were just over
eleven thousand the company's loss
coming in a little bit smaller than had
been estimated but again Emily it's
really that deliveries number that's
important and the shares are down uh
they've been gyrating a little bit but
down call at five six percent in the
after hours after growling about twenty
one percent for the year today
interesting also a Model X production
they're saying challenges with that
production could slow down output for
the Model S Eric I want to bring you in
here what's the significance of this the
Model X is going to be a critical
vehicle for Tesla we're seeing the
utility segment is on fire right now
it's in big growth mode in a growing
industry it's very important for Tesla
to nail this Model X deliverable and
it's already two years delayed so they
need to get this product out as soon as
they can see you know what do you make
of all this given the diversification of
products we're seeing at Tesla from the
cars and the different models to now the
battery which is still not out yet but
they're taking orders for the battery
excuse me sir
so can't go ahead but yeah thank you the
point of reducing the the forecast the
sales forecast this year I personally
don't think it would have been very hard
for that the
company to beat its original forecast
55,000 and and I think what what it has
to do is just sell the same number of
X's that it sells of the yes it can
still do that I think that it is setting
itself up to have a blowout
fourth-quarter and go ahead and and and
meet the original production target but
what Elon Musk is doing I think is he he
is stepping back he's showing that he's
far more flexible in in in in terms of
how he's going to meet his targets meet
his 2020 targets were remember he's
seeking to sell 500,000 cars a year by
then
so he's he's going into new chemistry's
he's bringing in new products he's
hiring very very good battery
technologists I think the year to look
at this year will be alright but the
year to look at is next year when it
went when he's going to come out with a
prototype for the model 3 during the
summer right and Julie we're still
getting some new headlines here Tesla
also saying that it's testing the
ability of various suppliers what else
is jumping jumping out at you right now
also saying they're increasing
investments in China right which is it
is potentially a huge market for for
Tesla if indeed you know the trend the
strong trend that they're seeing there
is continuing and what you were saying
about testing ability of many suppliers
seems to speak to the companies saying
that Model X production challenges could
slow work on the model as another
headline that cross caught my eye has to
do with pricing the company says the
third-quarter Model S average sales
price it predicts it will drop by more
than 100 basis points so interesting
there that it's seeing a little bit of
perhaps pricing pressure when it comes
to the Model S Eric you know China's but
in Tesla's been pouring more and more
money into China what is your outlook
for the China market in particular well
we've just seen warnings this week from
Toyota and BMW about the slowdown in
China some of the macroeconomic factors
they're impacting sales in fact
we see sales flat this year only the
first time we've seen flat sales in
China for 17 years so it's something
that automakers are around the globe
were paying particular attention to and
could have a big negative impact for
brands that are dependent on the Chinese
market for growth such as Tesla Tesla
also now saying they plan to reveal the
design for the model 3 in the first
quarter Steve what can you tell us Eric
what can you tell us about the model 3
model 3 is expected to come in in 2018
assuming there are no hiccups with the
production there it's this is the
everyman Tesla they're calling it it's
very important to transition that brand
from being a niche performance luxury
automaker into a mass-market vehicle
it's all hinging on this vehicle that's
in that sweet spot in the estimated to
be 40 to $50,000 pricing range which is
right around where we see a lot of the
competitors on the gas engine
counterpart with the 3 Series in the C
Class and some of those competitive
vehicles so they're talking a lot about
production challenges about operational
challenges for deliveries now in the
fourth quarter Steve I want to talk to
you about production of the battery and
the gigafactory obviously there the
Tesla's been buying up land around the
gigafactory what does all this mean for
the success of this battery using that
as a pivot point the ability of Tesla to
pivot from its niche status now into a
major car maker relies on the
gigafactory
on the batteries being able to bring
down the price of the batteries
significantly and if Tesla could end up
Oh on the factory floor remember the
Concorde it could end up Tesla could end
up as this very very good car that
everyone thought a lot of but that never
reached its its potential because it was
unable to bring down the price the model
3 is it's proven test led to the
Concorde
I'm saying it's dream
you know it could end up as the Concorde
if it doesn't bring its price down Tesla
has to bring down the the price of the
car the model three has to come down
between actually not 40 or 50 but
between 30 and 40 if it can do that it
will break into the mass market then it
will be a success I I wonder though if
there were some safety issues with the
Concorde that Tesla certainly doesn't
appear to have at this point Steve
closing thoughts on Tesla of course
we're continuing to watch the headlines
roll in we'll be listening to the call
coming up in just a few moments
listening to any color that Elon Musk
has to add to all of these points we
mentioned but Steve what are the number
one thing what is the number one thing
that you're going to be listening for
well what Oh Eric excuse me home Eric
what is the number one thing you're
gonna be listening for like I'm really
curious to see when that Model X will
launch I think in the immediate term the
Model X is critical to them closing out
the year successfully as I mentioned
before it's a growing segment but I've
also heard a lot of reports about Model
S owners that are really anticipating
and waiting for their Model X and we'll
see how long these enthusiastic owner
base for Tesla's can actually wait until
they might either keep that Model S that
they already have and cancel a Model X
purchase or move on to another
alternative vehicle that might satisfy
their utility needs